من جده تنضم الينا الفائزه بمسابقه
المهارات الثقافيه اسرار الجهني اسرار
صباح الخير
من وين جبت هذه الموهبه منو في اسرتك ممكن
يمثل او يقلد او استقيتي منا هذه الموهبه
والله لوحدك
بروحك لا زمان كان بابا يمثل بالمسرح كنت
اشوفه وكان نفسي اصير نفسه
فشفته
وحققت حلمي وصرت نفسها الحمد لله
وما شاء الله عليك يا اسرار يعني مش بس
بتمثلي باللهجه السعوديه ولكن بكل اللهجات
سمعناكي تحكي لبناني مصري
اهتمامك باللهجات المختلفه كيف تعلمتي كل
هذه اللهجات
العربيه المتنوعه
بس احفظ واحاول اتمكن منها وخلاص
بس الحفظ وحده مو كافيه حتى قاعد تغيرين
بطريقه الكلام
والتمثيل هذا شلون
شكرا شكرا لا داعي للتصفيق ههه
ما شاء الله عليك يا اسرار حبيبتي طيب
اوكي يا اسرار طيب هلا شو ناويه تعملي
بالمستقبل هل فقط هاي الموهبه راح تبقى في
حدود
هوايه ام ممكن انك انت تحترفي تمثيل في
المستقبل او تاخدي الموضوع يعني بشكل
اكاديمي اكثر
لا انا فكرت اني راح اتطور واحاول اتطور
اكثر واكثر واكثر
واصير
ممثله مسرحيه مشهوره الله مسرحيه كمان
تحديدا اسرار يعني خليني اتكلم عن
المسابقه شوي المسابقه شلون لقيتي فيها
التنافس شو اللي شو اللي لفت نظرك بانه
والله صعبه لا ممكن اني انا افوز على
الجميع شو اللي حسيتي فيه كلميني عن
هالتفاصيل هذه
قولي لي الاسرار يا اسرار يلا اول شيء
المسابقه ايوه
كانت الاستاذه تقول لي انه شاركي انت عندك
مقاطع حلوه للمسرح وزي كذا فانا رحت قلت
لاختي واختي يلا شاركي وما توقعت بوصل هذا
الانجاز
طيب بين كل اللهجات اللي بتمثل فيها
يا اسرار اي وحده اقرب شيء لقلبك اكيد
السعوديه يعني غير السعوديه خلينا نقول من
اللهجات الاخرى
لبنانيه المصري
لبناني
يلا احكي لنا شويه لبنان طيب
شو بدك احكي
احكي
لبناني شوي
انت كمان ما شاء الله عليك
طيب يا اسرار شكرا جزيلا
لاسرار الجهني مشاهدينا الفائزه
بمسابقه المهارات الثقافيه كانت معنا من
جده بالتوفيق
لتحققي كل احلامك على مسرح الاوسكار ان
شاء الله ان شاء الله قواك الله
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات